Luke, I am your father.
That's not how he sounds. He's not Batman.
Jesus.
Luke...
Oh that is way better.
I am your father.
Oh you have not known how long I've been wanting to taste the blue milk
That's how they drink in the damn universe.
Ooh! That's Yoda. Done.
I like the lightsabers.
(Lightsaber sounds)
Oh no, it broke my --
I won!
Cheers, I have blue milk.
It doesn't take like anything.
It looks like Lucky Charms, but it tastes like Fruit Loops.
Which is tripping me out.
Oh God!
There's like so much sugar in this. It's amazing.
Jedi Gels!
I feel like this is what Jedis have to eat so they stay energized during battle.
Let's give it a shot...
Oh my God. Wow.
Oh man. That's delightful. I love it.
Mmmmm. No?
Jedis seem pretty fit.
Like Obi-Wan seemed like a stud back in the day in Episode One and I don't think he was eating these.
If you were a kid in the lunch room,
"I'll give you C-3PO for R2D2."
"I'll trade you my Yoda for it."
I got a bunch. You want C-3PO?
Yeah, I'll take a C-3PO.
I'll eat your Yoda.
Nice.
Is this a lightsaber?
Yes!!
Not as satisfying as in the series, but..
Oh sh**!
(Lightsabers humming)
Oh my God, I just got a huge nerd boner. It was great.
I wonder if this is what the Jedis go through when they get their new lightsabers
and go through a shit ton of plastic.
Now we gotta assemble it.
No, this is not good. No it isn't.
After all that work it should taste like something. Right?
What's your flavor?
I feel like my flavor is just sugar.
I feel like it would taste better if it had a little bit of a sourness
but this is just straight up sweet.
You know what? I think I'm done.
This is not for eating. This is for play only.
Oh my God, I'm so happy!
I need this in my life.
I could almost cry right now.
Oh my gosh. He's wearing the full Groucho Marx..
To avoid copyright issues.
Oh my God.
It's already my new favorite beer. I don't even have to try it.
It smells delicious and let's just say that.
Alright. Cheers.
That is so good. I dig.
I love it.
It kinda tastes like coffee.
Mm-hmm!
Yep. Yeah.
It had a bit of a bite at first, which confused me
but then once I got into it, it was great.
I just picture me on the canteen on Tatooine
and I just order one of these bad boys.
Just getting turnt with some intergalactic buzz.
Chewbacca would drink this.
Mm-hmm. I see that.
I bet Chewbacca's a drunk.
That's why he can't talk. Right?
He's just wasted all the time.
He actually speaks English, but it just comes out..     Can you do an impression?
(Chewbacca roar)
It's like you need to get your vocal chords to flap together
(Chewbacca impression)